since his debut in 1962 the Mighty Thor
has been one of the Marvel Universe's
most powerful heroes even if you're
caught up on his adventures can recite
the inscription on his hammer from
memory and know the name of the magical
metal it was crafted from
here are a few things about Odin's
favorite son that you'd be surprised to
learn
Kirby's three Thor's when Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby were creating the Marvel
Universe in the 60s they had already
been working in comics for twenty years
with that in mind it might not be
surprising that journey into mystery
number 83 wasn't Kirby's first shot at
doing a story about the Norse god of
thunder that honor goes to adventure
Comics number 75 in a story by Kirby and
his Captain America collaborator Joe
Simon the Golden Age Sandman goes up
against a crook named fairy tale Fenton
who masquerades as the hammer swinging
Thunder God in order to pull off daring
robberies after injuring the Sandman
sidekick and sparking a full-on riot
Fenton has finally brought down and sent
packing never to be seen again 15 years
later Kirby would hit a little closer to
the mark with tales of the unexpected
number 16 a 6 page story called the
magic hammer featured a Thor with plenty
of familiar design elements and a
version of Mele near that looks an awful
lot like the one that would show up at
Marvel at the start of the next decade
it was even hidden on earth until it was
found by a mere mortal who could tap
into its power although in this case it
was discovered by a cowboy crypt named
bard who was anything but worthy the
real twist though while Kirby's third
shot at Thor would be a success for the
fledgling Marvel comics both the Sandman
story and tales of the unexpected were
published by DC journey into mystery
building off the success that they'd
found by introducing the Fantastic Four
the previous year Lee and Kirby decided
in 1962 to expand their superhero
universe and the mighty thor charged
into the pages of journey into mystery
number 83 for the most part the stone
men from Saturn follows the usual beats
of the sci-fi monster comics that Marvel
had been publishing in the 50s
aliens invade Earth but get scared off
when they encounter someone who's strong
enough to stand against them the big
difference is that the someone is of
course dr. Don Blake who finds a cane
tucked away in a cave in Norway that can
transform him into Thor but there's
another important character who made his
debut in that issue in 2006 the Planet
Hulk storyline revealed that one of
those stone men from Saturn fled back to
the stars and wound up stranded on the
planet sakaar
living as a gladiator his name is Korg
and while a similar Rock Monster
appeared in the opening of Thor the dark
world and a tribute to that first issue
Korg himself would wind up being a
significant character in Thor Ragnarok
dr. Don who Marvel superheroes are often
defined by having disadvantages in their
civilian identities that bleed into
their heroic exploits Ironman had to
wear the chest plate of his armor all
the time in order to keep the shrapnel
from moving closer to his heart
spider-man was perpetually broke and
struggled with school for Thor the
consequence of losing control of his
hammer for 60 seconds was that he would
turn back into his human identity dr.
Donald Blake a disabled doctor who
worked with his nurse and love interest
Jane Foster in the 80s Marvel introduced
a big twist Don Blake didn't actually
exist instead
Thor's human form was created by Odin in
order to teach his son the folly of his
arrogance by imprisoning him in the body
of a human Odin hoped that Thor would
stop bragging and learn to put the needs
of others before his own considering the
stories we've gotten since it's safe to
say that it worked
tales of Asgard while Thor himself was
in the spotlight Lee and Kirby added an
awful lot to Marvel's version of the
Norse pantheon to help distinguish it
from the classic mythology the tales of
Asgard back up stories adapted myths and
helped introduce new characters like
Fandral the dashing Hogan the grim and
Volstagg the voluminous better known as
the Warriors 3
have a cup of spies
everything you need to know about these
three characters is right there in their
names
Fandral is a swashbuckler based on the
on-screen exploits of Robin Hood actor
Errol Flynn
while Hogan was a fearsome fighter that
according to Lee was based on Charles
Bronson Volstagg was inspired by
Falstaff from Shakespeare's Henry the
fourth an aging warrior who often
exaggerated his own accomplishments and
was eventually revealed to have an
equally voluminous wife and about a
dozen kids the warriors three quickly
became fan favorite supporting
characters and even managed to spin off
into a few stories focused entirely on
them as a leading trio the Thor Corps
when Walt Simonson took over Thor in
1983 for a truly definitive run on the
character one of the biggest changes he
made was the introduction of beta ray
bill an alien everyman who looked like a
cross between an orange humanoid and a
skeletal horse bill was the chosen
defender of his race as they fled the
destruction of their home planet after a
cosmic misunderstanding led him into a
brutal battle against Thor he proved he
was worthy to hoist the hammer and Odin
granted him one of his own Stormbreaker
bill wasn't the only other Marvel
character to ever wield the power of
Thor in 1988 Tom DeFalco and Ron friends
gave Thor a new secret identity in the
form of Eric Masterson an architect
who's inexperienced with godly powers
gave him a pretty big challenge in
crime-fighting
in 1993 two characters were separated
but Eric continued his heroic career as
Thunder strike wielding a magical mace
with the same name in Thor number 384
they introduced Dargo Couture a resident
of a 26th century dystopia who lifted
milner and became that eras version of
Thor needless to say he crossed over to
the core Marvel Universe to battle the
Fantastic Four on the orders of Zarko
the tomorrow man no really that's the
actual name of a Marvel character with
all these Thor's running around
time they obviously had to form a team
thus was born the Thor core in which
Thor beta ray bill Thunder strike and
Dargo United for a battle across time
and space that would basically prove how
wild comics of the 90s could be the
Incredible Hulk returns until the launch
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe The
Incredible Hulk TV show was one of
Marvel's greatest mass media successes
it ran for five seasons and gave the
Hulk one of the most memorable
catchphrases of all time when Bill Bixby
and Lou Ferrigno returned as banner and
his green alter ego for a series of TV
movies Marvel used that popularity to
shift the spotlight on a few of their
other characters the second trial of the
Incredible Hulk would use its courtroom
setting to introduce TV audiences to
Marvel's resident attorney daredevil but
the first one hit The Incredible Hulk
against the Mighty Thor in this case
Thor was played by Erik Kramer and while
his TV appearance did include Don Blake
it wasn't his Thor's alter ego instead
Blake found himself in a sort of Aladdin
situation where Thor was compelled to do
his bidding leading to a pretty weird
scene where Blake and Thor hung out in a
bar trying to decide whether Thor should
take up a career as a crime fighter
klore goes bad in 2006 the Marvel
Universe was divided in the Civil War
crossover on one side iron man was
pushing for and eventually enforcing the
superhuman Registration Act which would
require all superheroes to sign up with
the government for training organization
and oversight on the other Captain
America and a band of rebels were
fighting against the SHRA in the name of
freedom and the slippery slope that
would inevitably lead to giant robots
rounding up mutants it stands to reason
that whichever side got Marvel's most
powerful heroes would have a pretty big
advantage but there was a problem the
Hulk was out in the depths of space and
Thor was temporarily no longer alive but
Tony Stark didn't let a problem like
that stop with a strand of Asgardian
hair and some pseudoscience he and Reed
Richards were able to cook up the pro
Registration sides ultimate weapon
a cybernetic clone of Thor that was
quickly dubbed core given how well
cyborgs and clones gone for you know the
entire history of comics it won't
surprise you that klore went rogue at
his earliest opportunity and ended up
blowing a hole through a hero called
Goliath while klore was smashed to bits
by Hercules at the end of Civil War he
was eventually rebuilt in christened
Ragnarok cropping up in the pages of
Dark Avengers before the real Thor
returned to Midgard and proved that
Ragnarok couldn't hold up to the genuine
article he should have brought more
Thor's Thor's identity has been pretty
malleable ever since beta ray bill first
hefted the hammer back in 1983 but
recent stories have seen more people
claiming the title than ever before
a 2013 story saw the arrival of gore the
god butcher a cosmic threat so dire that
in order to defeat him Thor had to team
up with the greatest warriors he could
think of himself twice together with a
young Thor who had yet to prove himself
worthy of Millner and an older one-eyed
one-armed version who had taken Odin's
role as all-father
they United to defeat the god butcher
it's a more gore Thor core in 2014 after
the Odinson z' worthiness was called
into question
Mjolnir found a replacement in the form
of a new thorn one whose arrival changed
the inscription to read if she be worthy
this Thor's identity was initially
played as a mystery but was eventually
revealed to be the original Thor's
former love interest Jane Foster whose
mortal form was dying of cancer she
proved herself to be more than capable
of living up to her namesake but during
a desperate struggle against the
monstrous mangog she was only able to
defeat him by hurling Milner into the
Sun apparently destroying him and ending
her own life in the process and Thor
girl we don't talk about Thor girl
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
you